What?
Just trying to keep it classy around Christmas. That's what we do around here, you know.
No, seriously, one thing I want kids growing up
knowing if they've been a part of our church is that it's possible
to have fun while still taking your faith very seriously.
That they grow up knowing that this church that
they had a great time at preach the
gospel.
Saying praise to our King and disciple them
towards Jesus and still had fun while they were doing it.
And so that's what we're here doing today. That's what we
do every week. We gather together is towards that end specially
in the season of Advent as we look to how
Jesus fulfills the longings of our hearts.
Towards hope and peace and joy and
love.
today in part but one day
Fulfill those things one day in full
that's what Advent does it. It aligns
us with what happened 2,000 years
ago. And those who are waiting before Jesus was born in
that Tiny Town of Bethlehem. It aligns us
with what they were waiting for because we're still waiting for
something and it stirs our hearts for what he will
bring one day when he comes back.
So today we're studying the fourth word of Advent which is love
And so take your copy of God's word and turn with me to first John
4 to see that first John
4 is where we will see that.
It's always almost to the end of the Bible. If you
hit the maps, you've gone too far. So come back a little bit through Revelation
first second. Third, John.
first John chapter 4
now we've had to do this every week because these words are so
broad. We have to define the word we're talking about so that
we can understand what we're even
talking about here because the reality is we throw this word
love around all the time. Like how
many of you love pizza?
Right you guys. Yeah, I'm there with you how many of you
love your mom? So now inherent in
that we know that we mean different things by that right unless maybe you
don't your mom's gonna feel really bad about that. So but
we know like there's there's differences the
way we use the word now thankfully in the original languages of
God's word. They actually had multiple words to say
those different things.
In the Old Testament Hebrew you had words for love referring to
the way a married couple would talk to each other and that kind
of love you had words that were the love we have for God the
Delight we have in him.
But there was one word that was most often used
for love. And that's the word that we've talked about over the
last few months here has said that that loyal
steadfast Covenant love
God has for his people.
Here's a good definition of it is that there is solid action
accompanying the feeling.
There is an affectionate feeling but there's action with it.
Well in the New Testament Greek you have many words as well
and some of you might have heard of the word phileo, which is more likely
there's basic relationship between people.
But like the Old Testament the New Testament had one
primary word for love and that's the word
that talks about God's love for us
our love for him.
Appropriate love for one another and
that's the Greek word gape.
Like has said was in the Old Testament Agape in
the New Testament.
It's used for how the Father and Son interact.
When the sun's baptized and the father says this is my beloved. That's
the root word Agape. It's how
we are supposed to respond to
God. It's what Jesus said his primary that we love God with
all that we are and we love our neighbor as ourselves, which is
what we'll talk about here in a second.
It's also what Paul said in First Corinthians
13 is the most important thing. It's this agape. Love
for one another.
In fact, it's so prevalent. Maybe the main theme
of the New Testament it is all over in
the the forms the various forms of
the word Agape in the New Testament 745 times.
That's how important this is to us.
Yet we still need a definition.
of love
what that has said and Agape were referring to how we're
going to use it today. What's the definition? Well, here's a
great one from one of my favorite authors named Paul Tripp. We
put it on your notes. You don't have to write it down. We'll put on
the screen as well. But here's how he defined love.
That it is willing self-sacrifice for
the good of another.
That does not require reciprocation or that
the person being loved is deserving.
They might try to write it down, but I'm gonna rephrase it. Maybe a little more simple here.
What you might say is that love is where you willingly give of
yourself for someone else's good.
Even if they can't pay you back and even if they don't deserve it.
That's true. Love.
It's not a feeling that you can fall into or fall out
of no matter what that country song tells you right you can't
fall into this feeling love is actually an action
love is a choice you make to act in
a certain way towards someone.
That's how Jesus can up the Annie on this and say love your
enemies.
Because let's be honest. It's really easy for us to
love someone that you feel the affection for right like
you somebody's really kind to you. You're gonna be kind to
them you're sacrifice for them. It's like no back and forth. It's always going
to be easy to do that. But the true essence of
love.
Is when you seek the good of those that you don't feel
that feeling for.
For that jerk coworker that you're thinking of right now.
For that neighbor who's always criticizing the way you do your
yard, whatever it like that that hard hard to
love church member that that one that you deal with
in your family that bully at school. Whatever it is like
that person. That's not easy to love.
Yet we're still commanded.
To love even those who are opposed to us.
So love has to be something different than just a feeling.
But it is a main theme of the scriptures.
In fact in just this short but powerful section. We're going
to study today.
Six verses hey kids
and students. I want you to do this as I'm reading through this count how many
times you see a variation of the form love?
Beloved loved loving anything just
count how many times in just six verses this word
shows up agape.
First Corinthians 4 look at verses 7 through 12
beloved
let us love one another.
For love is from God and whoever loves has
been born of God and knows God.
Anyone who does not love does not know God because God
is love.
In this the love of God was made manifest Among Us that
God sent his only son into the world so that
we might live through him.
In this is love not that we have loved God, but
that he loved us and sent his son to be the
propitiation for our sins.
Beloved if God so loved us. We also
ought to love one another.
No one has ever seen God.
If we love one another God abides in us
and his love is perfected in US.
God we need you to see what you want us to see open
our hearts our minds our our eyes to see
how you want to affect our lives with
this very passage today.
Show us your love show us how to love.
Change our hearts towards love today for your glory in
Jesus name. Amen.
Now as I hope you can see as I was reading through that there's really only one main application
Point here and it's pretty simple like what we do.
Love one another isn't that
complicated today? Love one another?
But here's the thing that command is actually implied here. It's not explicit but
it is there.
Because in verse 7. It's it's in what we call
the subjunctive mood, which means it's more like he's pleading
with his readers to to love.
He's like a pep rally kind of like come on guys. Let's love
we need we need a love like this guys. Let's this what
we need to do.
Then in verse 11, it's more of a conditional statement that
assumes positive response.
So it's not if God has loved us like this. He's saying since God
has loved us like this. This is
what we do.
we love
Right, so this is assumed but it's there
and remember this this love one. Another command was a
close second to Jesus when he was asked to summarize
the law he gave them the great commandment.
And first was love God with everything you are.
But he said a second is like it.
To love your neighbor as yourself.
And so what he's saying in that is he's not saying there's there's two
commands. He's saying the way you love God with all
that you are is by loving others by
loving your neighbor as yourself, you're you're willingly
self-sacrificing for the good
of those around you even when they don't deserve it and even
when they can ever pay you back.
That's love according to God.
Okay, so it's pretty simple. We know what we're supposed to do. Right? Let's go go. Love one
another right? Well, okay, what why?
Why should we love one another?
Well, you saw a couple reasons here. We know we could
just say we should love but but there's there's basis behind
it. Look at what verse 7 says.
It says that love is from God.
That's one reason we should love one. Another is because love is from
God. This is the only way we know
what Love Actually is is how
he loves us.
It's from him. It's like growing up watching my my
grandpa. Love my grandma.
By the way, my grandma's sitting right over here today. It's kind of an honor for that, but it
wasn't perfect.
But I learned how to love my
wife today.
By watching him love her as he
did.
serving giving and sacrificing
not at all for himself, but just to give away and so
I learned Love by watching him love is
from God. We love now because
he first loved us.
He gives love he is the distributor and
definer of love but we have to
ask the question. How do we even know? What love is how do we know what God's love
even looks like
Well, thankfully we have some pictures of that.
The first is because his love according to
this passage was revealed on Christmas.
His love was revealed on Christmas.
Look at verse 9.
In this in other words what I'm about to say in this
the love of God was made manifest Among Us that
God sent his only son into the world so
that we might live through him.
see that
God sending his son into the world
is how his love was made visible.
How his love was made evident manifest how
his love was revealed was through Christmas?
That's the gift. We celebrate at Christmas, right John 3:16 for
God so loved the world. God loved the
world in this way. We might say.
That he sent his only son.
And whoever believes in him would not perish but have eternal life.
This was God's Christmas present to us.
Was his son.
He gave because he loved.
We shouldn't start with our fickle examples of Love here on
this Earth because just think about the people you love the
most.
You've hurt them at some
point, right?
They've hurt you.
And so even in our fickle love we we hurt
each other, but we shouldn't start then with that as our picture
of love.
We should start with God.
That his love of sending his son.
Is How We Know What Love looks like
So his love was revealed at Christmas, but also this passage
shows us that it was proven on Good Friday.
His love was proven.
Look at verse 10 on Good Friday.
In this is love now. This is
entering you can't see this in the English translation, but in the Greek original
language it says in this is the love.
Like so so this is the it love like this
is the top you don't get anything better than this in. This
is the love the defining love of every other
type of love the love. Not that we've loved God.
But that he loved us and sent his son
to be the propitiation for our sins.
So notice this Christmas present God loved us enough to give was
not just sending Jesus to go hang out with people do some
cool Miracles and then head back home.
Now there was a purpose to the sending.
The father sent Jesus to be what?
the propitiation for our sins
Now that's a long big word. I know let's practice that for a second
so you can use it at Christmas next week with your family, right? So, let's say
it propitiation, okay?
Won the world is that even mean we don't use that in Daily
Language. And so what does it mean? It just means a lot.
Let's say it that way.
This is actually John taking a pagan
word from classic Greek and
changing its meaning to give it a theological
basis.
The originally these Pagan worshipers would
go their Temple and they would worship whatever God and they
would they would make these gifts.
To their God to appease his wrath and
hopefully win over his favor.
Basically, they were taking presents to this gift this God to
try to win him over and try to to buy them off so they
don't have any wrath and that they they know he's gonna be
on their side all of that kind of thing, but the big difference here that
John uses this term
He's he's saying in a way reminding us that hey remember Yahweh
does not need any gifts.
To win his favor towards us because God
already loves us.
He already has affection and favor towards us
yet at the same time. He's also
holy.
And his Justice towards sin will only be
satisfied.
through the penalty of death
and so you can bring all the gifts you want over here. You can do all
these things to try to win him over and get them on your side actually.
God doesn't need any gifts from you.
Yet he does demand death for sin.
That's why.
When Jesus was hanging on the cross.
He's about to die.
What did he shout he shouted it is finished.
Was he talking about he's talking about his life. No, he's talking
about this.
That he had satisfied in his death
on the cross the demands of the law.
That all of the the penalty of sin
that was due to the sinner.
the death demanded
Jesus said I did it. It's finished.
I took penalty.
I love how Spurgeon said it. He said the debt was
now to the last penny all discharged.
The atonement and propitiation were made once and for
all and forever.
by the one offering made in Jesus body on the
tree
There was the cup hell was in it
the Savior drank it not a sip
and then a pause not a swig and then a ceasing he
drained it till there was not a drop left for any
of his people.
All the judgment on sin was carried and
finished on the cross.
Like what what great love is this?
Well, we could never love him well enough.
We could never earn our way to him yet. God loved
us and sent Jesus to be nailed on that
cross to die in our place.
And that's what reconciled us to him as it wiped away
the Obstacle of sin that kept us from
him previously.
We now have access.
What great love is that is that not
the perfect demonstration of what Paul trip defined as
love?
Right that that nowhere else nowhere else.
Do we see that willing self-sacrifice Illustrated like
what Jesus did
especially
since we could never repay him for it.
And especially since we don't ever deserve it
at all.
Romans 5:8 God showed his love for
us in this that while we were still sinners Christ
died for us.
That's how we see his love is proven.
In his death on Good Friday.
Love is from God.
Now, why does he get to Define love and nobody else?
I mean, why don't we get to Define love because we Define it certain ways and
we would enjoy this or enjoy that why does he get to say What
Love Is
Well, because God is love
according to first John 4.
He defines love because he is it that's
the other verse the reason verse 8 gave us for why we ought
to love one another not only is Love from God love is part
of his nature.
God is love.
That's what it says right here.
Not here's maybe a shift in your thinking not just is
God loving towards you.
He is in his very nature love.
He defines it. He makes it up we
go back to this all the time, but when God told Moses in
Exodus 34 about himself.
Just listen to what God says.
The Lord, this is Yahweh the Lord
a god merciful and gracious.
Slow to anger abounding instead
fast, love and faithfulness.
That's that Hess said steadfast love. This is
who he is. He is love here's
the problem with this.
Unfortunately many people have flipped
that around in our day.
And said love is God.
and so whatever I feel
whatever makes me happy.
That defines everything else.
or even saying that
God is only love.
So I can do whatever I want because there's no ramification of their
side.
And you better celebrate it because this is who I am.
Listen, none of that's true, right?
None of that is true.
It's like a diamond has so many facets.
God is love but also God is Holy.
Remember, he's he's holy and listen, that's a good thing that
he's holy because that means he's going to fix what's broken someday.
He is just
that he's one day going to make right all that has been
wrong. He's going to set right and clear away all
the evil. That is good news for us that he's
holy and he's just
But it should also cause us to pause a little bit of how we're living
how we're talking how we're believing.
But listen, even even the justice
of God the Holiness of God is driven by
his love.
Because what's he doing?
In clearing out the evil. What's he doing in
in setting everything right for his people? He's
working for their good.
He's working for our good if we are his people he's working for our
good which is part of the definition of love, right?
willing self-sacrifice for the good
of another he's working for our best that Justice.
Is driven by his love?
so love is who God is
since he's loved us like this. We should love
others as well.
But here's what I want to I want you to see in this is that not
only does it give us motivation to do this
because of what he bases this off of but also he
lays out results.
He shows us what will happen.
when we love
when we live out this kind of love in response
to his love for us. Here's what's going to happen.
The first point is clear.
when we love
our faith is shown.
First John 4 says that whenever we love others our
faith is made evident.
Look again at verses 7 and 8.
Beloved let us love one. Another for love is from God and whoever
loves has been born of God and knows God.
Anyone who does not love does not know God because God
is love.
Now John does not pull any punches here.
Very direct speaking about the affirmative
that those who love or
this way, but also warning those who are
not loving.
And he says here that if you have received God's love
for you, you will love others like this is part
of the deal.
If you have received his love, you will
love others and what that will do is improve two things. It'll
prove first that you have been reborn of God.
Now that means like a spiritual rebirth that you've
been given a new life as second Corinthians 5 says
you've been made a new creation. You've been given a new heart whose heart.
if God's heart
God is love love is from God.
So if you have his heart what's going to come out of you?
Love right. That's the point you you've proving that
you have been born of God, but the
second Point you're also proving that, you know, God.
Not just that, you know about God.
But like Buddy the elf with Santa right like I know him, you
know God.
Like I know a lot about chip gains.
But I know my wife, you know, you see a difference like
that. I know those things differently.
This is the idea here is that you actually know God you
have a relationship with you're proving that you know him
and who he is.
films out of you
Loving others proves your faith, but the counters also true here.
You see that in verse 8.
Anyone who does not love does not know God because
God is love.
Now this might be the hardest part of this whole thing.
because when you go around our city
or our area region, whatever and you ask most
people
They would consider themselves a loving person wouldn't they?
most everybody would
Of course, we're loving of course. We're loving I'm not murdering anybody. Of course.
I'm a loving person. Right? Like that's what we would all say.
With so much of what we call love today.
is demanding
selfish
it's transactional.
It's conditional.
It's
it's what's in it for me. That's what kind
of what we call love.
Like yeah, I'll love you. I'll love you as long
as in the end I get that.
or
or I'll love you.
Until you go too far.
I'll love you.
until you don't
look attractive to me anymore.
Like you see how conditional and transactional and
all these things are are not true. Love at all.
because Jesus said
we must love even our enemies.
That's you're not going to feel anything for them. That's a
different level of love, right?
But that's the whole point of this.
That's the whole point of what he's talking about here. This is
the measure.
See how we know that we've been transformed by God's
love for us is when we love people who don't
love us back.
That's how you know, you really are a loving person. Look at
first, it's not in first John. It's in Luke. Luke says
this this isn't sermon amount recording what Jesus said Luke 6
32 through 35. He says if you love those who love you what
benefit is that to you?
For even Sinners love those who love them.
Of course, they're gonna yeah, you're kind your transactional.
It's all gonna go back and forth really? Well, of course, I'm gonna love
them.
And if you do good to those who do good to you. What benefit is
that to you? Even Sinners do the same?
And if you lend to those who from whom you expect to receive what
credit is that to you even Sinners lend to Sinners to
get back the same amount.
That's what the world does. Jesus says though.
Love your enemies.
And do good.
and lend
expecting nothing in return
And your reward will be great and you'll be
sons of the most high for he is kind to The Ungrateful
and the evil.
He's not saying you can earn your salvation. He's saying if you
truly have been born of God, if you're a child of
God, that's how you are going to live.
You're going to give and do good
and and lend without anything wanting to
come back on you like you don't want anything back. It's just Who You
Are.
Because again, it's easy to love those who love
you.
Who pay you back who give a lot to you as well? It's super simple,
but it's christ-like to love those who hate
you.
It's Christ like to love those who who you
want to to not be around very much, but you still sacrifice for
their good as well.
Now I know what you're thinking.
But aren't they going to start taking advantage of me?
What do you think happened to Jesus?
Jesus whole life was sacrificing was giving
away was serving so that other people could benefit.
He was helping other people flourish.
And the religious leaders killed him for it.
And yet even in that Jesus allowed that death.
for our good
even that was others focused.
How do you know?
This listen I marinated this all week. And this was
hard.
How do you know if you really are loving person?
Because this standard is looking like whoa, I
mean none of us.
How do we know if we are actually a loving person or not?
Well don't start by comparing yourself to
other decent human beings in Middle America.
Because when you start looking around like yeah, I'm a loving person. I mean
because everybody else is that's what we do. I let people go at the stoplight
and all that. Yeah. I'm a kind person. I you know, I'm loving.
But but listen, our standard should be higher than that.
Our standard should be Jesus and the way he lived
his life because that blows everything. We're doing out of
the water here.
Here's some questions to start asking to really dig into
whether you are a loving person or not.
Do I truly sacrifice for others?
Is my life all about me?
Do I do whatever I want without considering others?
Think about that in a marriage.
family
Do I reach across boundaries?
To be with people who are not like me.
To love and care for those where it might be
a little more challenging. It might be something that's going to confront some things in my
heart. Do I love like that?
Do I ever affect my own comfortable Lifestyle
by how much I'm generously giving to
other people.
that's
that's a deep do it. Does it ever cost you anything?
to give
maybe even
This week sometime this afternoon.
reading through
a passage of scripture that the heading in my
Bible says marks of the true Christian
something we should listen to.
But listen to Romans 12:9 through 21 describe.
a lifestyle of love
let love be genuine.
Abhor hate what is evil?
Hold fast to what is good.
Love one another with brotherly affection.
outdo one another in showing honor
do not be slothful or lazy and Zeal
be fervent in spirit serve the Lord rejoice in
Hope be patient in Tribulation be constant
in prayer.
Contribute to the needs of the Saints and seek to
show hospitality.
It's going to dig deeper now bless those who persecute
you.
Bless and do not curse them Rejoice with
those who Rejoice weep with those who weep even unbelievers
live in harmony with one another do not
be haughty prideful but associate with
the lowly never be wise in your own sight.
Repay, no one evil for evil.
But give thought to do what is Honorable in the sight of all.
if possible so far as it depends on you live peaceably with
all
beloved never avenge yourself, but leave it to
the wrath of God for it is written vengeance is mine.
I'll repay says the Lord.
To the contrary if your enemy is hungry feed him
if he's thirsty give him something to drink.
For by so doing he'll eat burning coals on his head.
And do not be overcome by evil but overcome evil with good.
Go through that and just start grating your life.
And listen, I know how difficult this is.
I mean again, we're looking at this and and we're thinking
that none of us are going to make it.
None of us are true Christians now. It's easy to look at
a moment of your week.
Or a strained family relationship and
you look at this and you think man I'm out question the
whole thing.
Blew up on my kid on Wednesday like I'm out. I guess
I'm not a Christian like no listen.
Don't judge your life in a sliver of time.
If that's true, none of us would make it.
What we should think of is more what are the trends of
your life?
Where is god making you more
like himself? How is he
growing you in love? How are you progressing towards Romans
12 more than you were a year
ago 10 years ago. Like I know it's gonna look like this when
you think of the trend upward it's gonna look like up and down
through your life day to day week by week, but the general Trend
should be towards Jesus.
Towards Christ likeness towards Romans 12.
Again, if you just judge it by one sliver it looked like this
for a second but over time.
What are the trends?
Are you allowing God to make you more loving?
Because Jesus said in John 13:35 our love for one another
will Mark us office his disciples.
That's talking to you as an individual me as an
individual and us as a faith family. In other
words. It's our love compelling to people around
us. Do they see it do they know that's one of our values as
a church compelling love that people see how much we
love each other.
And they they see Jesus they they're compelled to want
to believe.
It's like it's like you have a birthmark from from birth, right?
You didn't earn it. You didn't manufacture that
you didn't try to get that your kids might ask you that a
lot. Right? Like what is this spot on my leg? Well, that's a birthmark.
our birthmark as Christians
is love
It's it's to be so compelling that people say.
You guys really are Christians. You're like Jesus.
because we love
so this is our faith is shown. Yes, but listen as we
celebrate Advent.
The coming of Christ 2,000 years ago.
This love is also how our God is seen
today.
It's how our faith is shown but it's also how our God is seen.
Remember what verse 12 said first John 4?
No one has ever seen God.
If we love one another God abides in us
and his love is perfected in us that perfected me
completed. It means finished.
It's like how you used to have to take a film
that you put in a camera kids. There used to be like these cameras
that you put this cartridge into and it would
spin a little bit. He had to take it to it. They take it into a dark
room.
And whatever was on that film would have to be developed
and the image would show up as it was being
developed.
this
when we love others is how
the image the picture of God the image
of God in us is developed.
to the world
It's how they see who he
is.
It's as we love that we have been reborn spiritually that
his love abides in us. And so since
he's in here he is What flows out of
us and he is love so we reflect his heart for 33
years. It was Jesus on the earth in bodily form.
They saw God there now. It's how
people see him through us.
I read somewhere that the church is God's audio-visual presentation
to a dying culture.
He throw it up on the Whiteboard. You got the
screen going got the graphs and the charts and all this stuff this
Church
is God's audio-visual presentation to the world
that this is who he is. This is what he looks like.
Let me just think about this.
When you walk around.
at your workplace and you are
Loving your coworkers, even though they're sitting in
the back room gossiping about you.
When we as a church take the massive amount of
resources God's given us and we just give away without any strings attached and
we're just loving churches and neighborhoods and and Ministries
all over the place without any worry that
they're ever gonna repay us. We're ever gonna get anything out of it. We're just
giving generously.
When you put your spouse and your kids
ahead of yourself at home.
What do they see?
They see God.
They see him he is love they see love lived
out. They know what it looks like.
My favorite verses is 2 Corinthians 3:18 and it
says beholding the glory of the Lord. We are being transformed
into the same image from one degree of
Glory to another this is the Christ likeness growing in
us as we behold the love of God for
us this great love of God for
us. We lift our eyes to him. It's changing us
to be more like him to be more loving like
he is
The life that he came to give us first John 4
says the more we live in that understand what that
life is like in Christ and he
loves us so deeply the more we will love others.
unbeliever This Is The Love
That you have been longing for your entire life.
the love of God
For you, it's not found in a person. It's not found
in a post.
The love of God for you, when you see your need
for that love of the Savior and you turn from
yourself and you turn to him and repentance and faith that
he died in your place.
That's the love that washes over you and fills you.
That you've always been empty.
This is the love of God you need.
but also believer
This is the love that was meant to Mark us off as his.
That no matter what you feel today. Remember this?
No matter what you feel today or no matter what you feel
tomorrow or whatever. It is Romans 8 says nothing.
Nothing can separate you from the love of God in Christ
Jesus.
He what kind of love the father has given to
us that we should be called children of God first
John three.
that in itself
an enemy of God now made a child of
God that means listen if you walked in here feeling unloved
you walked in your feeling unworthy for whatever
reason see this if God has taken you
from death to life from enemy to child. That means
you're his
and that means you're worthy.
He loves you more than you can ever imagine.
This is shown in his gift.
of Christmas Good Friday and his gift of Resurrection
and his gift of his holy spirit living inside of you
Christian.
He loves you.
He saved you and now hear me. He is empowered you
to go love other people just like he's loved you.
rest in his love
It's the fourth candle. We're going to light today fourth candle
the Advent wreath.
Hope then peace then joy, and now love is added
to that. I want to invite the radial family up here
to lead us through that they serve in our kids and
students Ministries. They serve as Celebrate Recovery
disciple making all kinds of ways. They're gonna read some
scripture about love.
Light the candles and then pray for us in
our heart towards the Messiah.
So let's worship together.
Romans 5 6 through 8 for while
we were so weak at the right time Christ died
for the ungodly for one will scarcely die
for a righteous person though perhaps for
a good person one would dare even to die. But
God shows his love for us in that while we were
still sinners Christ died for us.
Will you pray with us?
Precious Holy Father. We thank you Lord for
your presence with us today and for all our Brothers and Sisters in
Christ here to worship you.
God as we continue on in this season of Advent and focus this
week on your love for us.
I'm so thankful for your word that reminds us
just how much truly love us.
God we can never do enough to earn your love and in our
sins. We are as far apart from you as the East
is from the West.
But God in the fact that you are love.
You gave us the best.
And most precious gift in your sons, Jesus Christ.
We thank you for his wonderful and perfectly timed
birth.
And for the Eternal salvation and forgiveness of
our sins you deliver to us through his
perfect life.
death and Resurrection
I pray God as Christ Believers and followers
that we would live out your love for us
as we seek to bring this Same Love.
To every person that has yet to hear this wonderful news.
And had their lives changed.
Father we thank you, and we love you
so much.
It's on the precious name of Jesus Christ. We pray
amen.